hey what's up guys thanks for tuning in
to are you garbage please make sure you
go
subscribe to the youtube channel that
way you get the videos as they come out
yeah do it welcome to another
exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley everybody out there
and welcome back to everybody's favorite
new podcast
this is are you garbage the show we sit
down with your favorite comedians we
find out they grew up classy
or if they're absolute trash i'm your
host holt lee coming at you
on a beautiful day here down the
basement down here in aunt hoodies
christmas came early if you notice we
got some mic stands in the building here
we could not be more excited
the stockings are stuffed by the chimney
with care
and hopes that's the perk man soon we'll
be there
my co-host is coming at you right next
to me take time writing these out
of the day people enjoy them i've heard
several
no one in this room i got a lot of good
yelp reviews on them i'm telling you
that right now
gang give it up for the ceo of ru
garbage he's got his name on the lease
he's got his name
on the [ __ ] back of the boat give it
up for kevin james ryan everybody
hey what's up guys the baldi pulling out
of the harbor the road
the ss rogaine what's up everybody
thanks for tuning in
uh thanks for all the support please
make sure you review subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube
those numbers are true to roof we
appreciate it also patreon.com
are you garbage you can sign up you can
get bonus episodes
of are you garbage bonus episodes of
hard feelings where it's just me and
foley going back and forth
a little bit behind the curtain you know
what i mean also at the end of every
month we're doing live streams
uh with the highest level where you guys
ask us questions we ask you questions
going to be a [ __ ] hoot get involved
baby for everybody who signed up
and don't forget pick up a little uh
pick up a little merch over there at
podcastmerch.com grab yourself a
garbagio tv let the kids wet their beaks
for the holidays keep you warm in the
winter times are
tight over here that's right how about a
nice big shout out to our producer
extraordinaire he put the whole thing
together he's the magic man working the
ones and twos
the t-bone the pride of chicago
toby mcmullen everybody hey how's it
going guys
anybody looking to meet up come on down
to the diversity rocking bowl
bowling we are in lane 12 we got two for
one pitchers
wednesday nights and gang we could not
be more excited to have our incredibly
special guest here with us today he's an
absolute get he's a [ __ ] dreamboat
right now he is a very funny stand-up
comedian podcaster and actor
as an actor you've seen him in the
action comedy horror cherry bomb
of course you've seen him on jeff ross's
roast battle and he is the co-host of
garbage days
and the big question about his mind
today is he garbage i don't know but the
kid's a looker
and he's got a tight little body on him
give it up for scott chaplin everybody
what's up gentlemen how are we going
you're good-looking dude you know that
come on saw it on occasion
no it depends now i got a little bit of
a [ __ ] face
no team beats covered right here yeah
but who's kind of you too
it's all right here yeah i remember i
remember
across the room going like this like
your whole face is right here i'm like
okay gonna remember that for the next 25
years
i look like a frog the kids can be me i
don't see that
you're a good looking guy though yeah no
cool too very cool guys 80s hollywood
you got your own sitcom
sure yeah sure yeah catching up with
scotty or something like that
doing some doing some hijinks around
that staircase coming down on the main
set
be a good time but buddy thank you so
much for coming in and sitting with us
um i know a little bit about uh where
you're from where you
where where you've been what's the
what's the full back story there's the
boy right yeah yeah there's a kid
from jersey uh born in patterson but
then moved to a small town paquanic
oh i know oh yeah okay are you from
jersey no i knew a girl in uh college
went to
that was from pequano ah we can talk
later oh marissa was her first marissa
on our own yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
my father was a cop and uh my mother she
was just a nice lady
but before before i was born she she
worked like the
forensics at the at the jail really yeah
and then she quit
because uh the guys were like immature
there or something
huh yeah why don't you examine my dick
she said like that like her boss like
they had had a head and he like spun it
around his head like oh
what petey pablo jesus christ
dude think about it it's [ __ ] a bunch
of north jersey mooks bunch of dudes
yeah you mean a couple of colored jokes
at the christmas party i didn't know
swinging people's brains around that's
[ __ ] up see i always worry that the
doctors take a peek at you when you're
when
when you're in there under surgery and
stuff like that oh why wouldn't they oh
they for sure do
[ __ ] well the words out now hey what
it ain't great kids there's a couple of
nurses at st mary's who are not thrilled
by me
do uh did your mom and dad meet that way
did they meet on the job
no no they they made each other in like
seventh grade or something
what and then they both kind of got into
criminal justice for
i think it was just a thing you know
like i mean i i guess now they're trying
to establish some rules where you need
like a college education
but then it was like a cop you just got
to pass it
yeah i think the test was it was like my
dad used to tell me it was like
your mother and your father's drowning
who do you save
and then you go like oh my mom yeah
probably yeah it's a good that's pretty
good
it can go either way most likely you're
in kid
yeah no it's definitely a career path
for you know
a lot of a lot of my family members are
cops your mom and your dad are drowning
but the jets game's on it's the fourth
quarter what do you do
no timeouts
[Laughter]
so hold on so your mom was a nice lady
small where was he a cop was he a cop in
your in your small town
county sheriff's department um oh that's
like that's
part of the pattern clifton okay
all right and this was this is all
because he retired
when i was like 11. he retired when i
was young okay and then he was just a
guy who sat on the couch
never changed outfits pension really
yeah just
literally had the same outfit until a
day died i think he was alive for like
12 years before
you know he passed when did he pass away
he was retired uh
it's it was seven years ago last week
okay so
yeah yeah yeah yeah all right i was 23.
and why did you guys move from uh to
this to the small town just
economics yeah he was just he he became
captain and i guess he had enough money
to get the [ __ ] out of patterson
and yeah you know he wanted us to get a
better education and then we
[ __ ] it up yeah yeah his kids yeah of
course
we did the yeah i mean
it's it's like they grew up with no
money they were like city kids they had
it hard
and then he hit it while you know we
were all
kind of grade school middle school high
school and then uh
the way they acted wasn't completely you
know noble or like wealthy or anything
they kind of acted shitty and so we kind
of acted
describe shitty and who's we how many my
father was just an animal person
just a piece of [ __ ] guy but like funny
you know when you go like oh my dad was
hilarious then you look back at it
you're like nah he just like made people
cry and i thought it was funny
he made my aunt eileen cry and that was
i was partying
it's so funny as an eight-year-old you
know like whoa i can't believe he
stuck it to her why didn't he make it
now you're like why are you fighting
everybody
why didn't you make her cry i just he
was just you know he was a drinker you'd
get drunk and then uh
and then he would fight so he made her
cry through insults yeah well cause i
didn't like
most of my childhood i didn't know him
well because he worked second shift
i'm sorry i'd be in grade school and
then he'd come home at like 11 30 at
night
so i'd only meet him when i would like
wake up at two in the morning and he was
throwing [ __ ] around or fighting
you know like yelling at my mother i
guess the only time i would see him up
until
up until he retired so they had a
volatile relationship yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah last few years it
was him on the couch here in the bed
oh okay yeah we've had a couple
instances for sure for sure
and who who's the we in the situation
bro how many brothers and sisters
two older sisters two older sisters how
far apart were they from you
one's a year and a half older than me
uh-huh uh and then one is ten years
and how did they shake out are they
they're good upstanding
citizen you know you know like they're
they're pitfalls here and there
sure sure yeah but regular people
they're awesome
okay yeah yeah one of them you know
thinks uh trump won
but hey you know still out i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna debate her and then she's
right that would [ __ ] suck
you know i gotta try to get some
cranberry sauce over here not like a
fistfight you know what i mean
yeah she's very you know she's a little
off the deep end but the other sister is
like a wiccan
is that the what's the wicked like a
witch yeah like a witch she got married
with like swords
wait hold on like all right like which
one is it is this the 10-year the one
that's ten years
that's a year and a half older than me
is the witch like a wiccan
yeah and the and the one that's ten
years older is a
which i didn't know i i was like oh
she's into the stuff
like went to the wedding there was like
some witchy [ __ ] you know and i'm like
ah she thinks it's
cute you know how like people who like
dumb like harry potter like
harry potter or like the people she
likes witches yeah
he's like oh that's like a silly thing
she likes i like wrestling whatever
and then my girlfriend borrowed a bunch
of books from her
and it was all like how to be a witch
your life is a witch they're all written
in black and she was like yeah your
sister's a witch i'm like my sister's
not a
[ __ ] what are you talking about it's
like i am a witch
the book yeah yeah no seriously i am oh
and
that came all together maybe five months
ago the black cat the frogs everywhere
come on she's a witch yeah the eye of
newt lying around yeah
she lives upstate you know she's
the cold and i dream of jesus son
[Laughter]
by the way that potion was fantastic
last night
um wow so they're in that scene okay
okay my other sister's got three kids
she had them you know she was one of
those people who was like oh one person
got a house
that i went to high school like when
they were 22. then i got to get a
[ __ ] house you know and then it was
like oh someone i know had a kid
i'm gonna have three kids yeah very
suburban yeah it's like
now she's sitting there like what
happened
yeah i have a lot of friends like that
yeah it's rough man yeah
all right so volatile situation growing
up a little bit i suppose but but again
like you know you look back at it i
don't want to [ __ ] on that guy
i think my childhood was very difficult
uh because of him i wish they weren't
together type of situation you know what
i mean
um but you know at the end of the day
he's fine
he got over it yeah like i'm a [ __ ]
often and i have my flaws sure you know
whatever
dude i remember i was i was playing with
my wife the other night and i was
it was over dinner and i was ready i was
so mad i was ready to throw the plate at
the wall
like i was just so angry and i'm like
i'm with you and it was this moment in
my head
if i [ __ ] launch this plate i am 100
my father there's no coming back from it
like i have made a choice to go down
this road i am my dad and that's it
and i [ __ ] chose not to and then
afterwards she's like you seemed really
angry i'm like you have
no idea lady i think it's tough for us
because you know we don't have kids so
like i
i often feel like my dad knows
situations like i can't put a piece of
furniture together
without getting mad i can't do anything
without getting married
i remember a specific stereo system like
cabinet my dad putting together
with a lineup of [ __ ] coors light you
know what i'm talking about
yeah it was it was you know what i mean
but i look back on that it's like
exactly what you're saying i wouldn't
i wouldn't want to change any of that
because it because it really does make
you who you are oh growing up with that
yeah no i mean but also at the same time
i go like damn i i wish
my mother had it bet you know like we
get to go oh my story
was interesting because i lived in a
motel but there was like somebody
then it's like oh my mother has a grown
woman lived in a motel for me no i'm not
talking like that that was her life
no no but you know what i'm like where i
i do uh
there are aspects of it where i go like
[ __ ] yeah dude i'm so glad i'm not like
a worm
or a [ __ ] and that's because you know
you're dealing with the psycho you don't
get to go
you know what's the what's the motel
situation when did that happen
uh just things got bad enough where he
flipped out
and broke everything and then the next
morning it was like hey we're
we're gone yeah this is how old are you
for that i was in seventh grade
wow that's a lot yeah yeah but then my
sisters
you know they thought it was like a
suite life of zach and cody oh
it's a motel so it's like could you grab
something from the vending machine
leah try the ice machine go ahead yeah
the bed vibrates then
you know the whole idea was oh uh he'll
he'll stop
drinking right that's like what you
think okay he'll disappear and he'll
have to make a choice
and so uh now he was just like dude
[ __ ] sweet the house is open my
white yeah so then we went back and it
was like oh hey whatever i remember
having a conversation at the dinner
table
and then he was like you all got to
check this out and he brought us
downstairs
and he built a bar
[Music]
he just built a bar while we were gone
he's like i like it
look at this [ __ ] thing and it's not
i mean it's nice
but just to know that's what he was
doing like his thought process is not
that like what he was doing was wrong
like
he was like wait till you went to like
as he was hammering he's like this is
going to blow their [ __ ]
yeah yeah this will make up for it it'll
add a little bit of legitimacy to the
drinking you know what i mean
yeah yeah that's [ __ ] great no i
didn't no nothing nothing natural
good childhood yeah yeah like dude
in the [ __ ] woods it really is like
the more you talk to people it's like
that's normal
it's no it's yeah it's normal i hope it
gets less and less normal but it's so
normal i mean like humans are flawed
like that's gonna happen they're gonna
drink they're gonna get it it's like
i don't know i mean we've had what this
is like our episode 70 something and
it's like
everything everybody that's like a
normal child yeah but we are talking to
[ __ ] lunatic comedians most of the
time
but you know like you think about quiet
kids growing up and you always go like
oh
quiet kids typically when i grew up they
were all so smart and this and that was
like what if they had it worse than all
of us
yeah yeah they just shattered that's why
you know that's why they paid attention
that's the stuff you didn't think about
when you were a kid like no it wasn't
until much older like
people that were like bullies or
whatever you piece it together you're
like oh his dad was probably
beating the [ __ ] out of him yeah it all
makes sense
um what a nice that was like that became
like a psa right it was
[Music]
um so suburban neighborhood
single-family home
yeah yeah bi-level okay what's bilo
split level probably what you have split
no no no no underground it's just bottom
floor
top floor i don't know how to do it yeah
yeah wait did somebody live on the top
floor
well it's us it's us yeah but it's a buy
level you walk in and there's a step
going up and a step going down
yeah that's split level to you that's
what we would call it a split level did
only one family live in the house
yes okay yeah that's when you walk into
your house one goes down one i mean i
guess you could technically that's a
california split level
oh okay yeah
you know i got like a in-ground pool by
the time i was in middle school
damn he's over here [ __ ] in the morning
i don't know
i'm good you got it oh i enjoyed my shot
that's great he was uh above ground pool
guy
i was an in-ground pool oh we hit an
above run pool for a minute you know
really but then we made that the captain
money came
down wow captain money came out lovely
how was the uh the in ground yeah did
you have a pool or a slide or anything
or a hot tub anything
or just the basics no just basic and
then you know uh
the laws at that time were like you know
you can't even have a diving board that
is springy
yeah it was just like the white one that
was on like a piece of block yeah yeah
yeah
it got real tight like the late 90s
early 2000s everyone was drowning
yeah i remember going to like the ymca
pool
like up in phoenixville where they had
like an outside pool and dude the high
dives it was like [ __ ]
it was like mount kilimanjaro oh yeah
and then all of a sudden just one day it
was all gone
water parks as a kid i saw a man die in
front of me at a water park as a kid
what water park i saw a guy
uh whatever one was in wildwood crest
oh yeah yeah yeah that's where i grew up
oh wow yeah
it's the only place we'd ever go raging
waters beer okay yes
here yeah maurice and marines you saw
dude die there yeah i'll stand in there
there's like four guys going a year at
that time i was i was waiting for my
sister to come down
a thing and i was standing on a big
cement block like the height of this
table
and a guy was waiting for his daughter
with me and he just passed out like he
stroke or something and when he fell
back
dude cracked his head open died he was
right next to you yeah he was like
convulsing and then and then the people
came over to help him
and then his daughter and his wife came
over like screaming to the skies oh my
god dude
man that dude that place wildwood
if you're not familiar it's like [ __ ]
people are trying it's pure
it really is pure it is the trashiest of
all times i found it because it's the
free beach
yes that in atlantic city are the only
two places with free beaches
so it really brings out the [ __ ]
dregs of society i.e my family
and growing up the story there is they
put it in the nor'easter i don't
remember the nor'easter was the one it
was like
you sit in with your feet dangled mm-hmm
like the roller coaster
that was like the first one on the east
coast or whatever it was this huge
[ __ ] deal
and some guy's hat flew off while he was
on it so he like jumped defense to go
try to get the hat
and some dude [ __ ] came down over the
loop and kicked his head right off
yeah [ __ ] yeah awful so many people
died in wildwood like
especially in the 90s it was wide open
there was always the story of the girl
on freefall the great adventure who had
a long ponytail
that was the one that just dropped you
down and it just ripped her entire scalp
off
how old were you when you saw the guy
when you saw the guy die next to you
like nine
oh nine or two do you think about that
for the rest of the vacation the rest of
the summer i remember
not just now brought up this has been a
weird ride home remember later that
night
being on the boardwalk and just telling
my mom like oh he's probably alive the
ambulance got that quickly
and she was like no way she's like no
no there's no no no play along ma will
you
what are you kidding me concrete 300
degrees what are you nuts
she's got a clavicle from that she's
always very honest with me yeah
i know i noticed that like right now as
i tell you it's because she i don't
think she had a lot of friends and when
your mother doesn't have a lot of
friends she just kind of like
treats you like a friend gossips with
you and goes she would always go like oh
my god look at her boobs
[Laughter]
sounds all right if you ask me like you
were bingo buddies or something like
that oh yeah i don't know
that's [ __ ] funny
[Laughter]
my mom always did the opposite she tried
to like shelter you from things
like my best friend died when i was in
kindergarten they didn't tell me until
like a year later
what'd they say he did [ __ ] i used to go
to this kid's house every day
and play with him he was like he was my
best buddy you know one day i showed up
and the mom was like no you can't come
out and play i didn't know what's going
on got on my big wheel rode home
but apparently i did that for like every
day for like six months
and he was sick and finally the mom was
like yo you gotta
tell this he's dead
yeah yeah basically his mom called my
mom was like you know tell her
tell the fat kid to take it easy and
then we moved
like just coincidentally like a few
months later and then like a year later
i was like hey mom am i when are we
going to go up and see robbie again
she like turned the radio down lit up a
cigarette i was like
it was a lionel richie song too so i
knew she it was something serious
she wasn't turning down krz on a [ __ ]
hot track
man told me no i i had every i had
actually seen it right out in front of
you
yeah and we had like the bot the illegal
box
uh so it was just porn constant for
cable
yeah you had the elite you had the
hotbox wait who was watching that cops
have that stuff yeah yeah because it's
yeah they're all they're on they're on
the no
they all do the thing i'm not saying
they do like the most illegal things
well like the cops aren't really in
charge
i mean everybody's got bootlegs now but
every cop in like the 90s and before had
bootleg [ __ ]
uh fireworks like we always had
fireworks around you confiscate them and
then you take them
it's [ __ ] great dude and then we had
a satellite i remember putting up like
an illegal satellite
and it had canadian channels french
canada we got french canadian porn
what the [ __ ] that would blow my mind
now it'd be cool if i started talking
french right now
yeah like if i had all learned from it
but no i was just like ah
wait who now or did your parents know
that you were watching porn
were they like open with it or no no
there wasn't you know
that it's not like open but like that's
not during dinner that's like hippie
territory yeah
well we both come like from very i
repressed irish
out yeah
you know it was just a thing porn and
gun you would just find it
guns everywhere yeah how old were you
when you were playing with guns
no i would never play with them i never
had any interest because they were
laying everywhere you know
jesus was guns laying around the house
not like
laying around but yeah under most
couches and [ __ ] yeah or under
yeah yeah yeah so he was ready to go
always oh wow
always always underneath him and then he
carried everywhere
if when he did leave the house uh he
would carry yeah sweet revolver
i don't remember i know i mean he can't
get in trouble now
but i know what he would do when he was
retired is his friends would come over
and he would switch over
like semi-automatic to fully
automatically just making illegal
guns and [ __ ] ready to rock and roll
just partying
i love it i got buddies that are in the
guns like you over their house there's
just like a [ __ ] ak or something like
i don't even know
i'm like is this legal dude they're like
yeah man it's cool i'm like
all right did you say so
well let's put it away because we're
wasted right now holy [ __ ]
all right so um gave us a little bit of
a paint a picture let's play a little rv
garbage
do it uh i'm leaning garbage no
you don't think so oh i think i'm
looking a good boy and i think that will
have to defy the garbage
i think you'll go oh my goodness okay
like it's a wonderful life or something
what makes you say that i don't know the
montreal snuff films that were
are the automatic weapons laying around
the house i don't know
but you know that's me seeing the things
you know but then what did i say i want
you to dive deep into this because i
said i never touched the guns sure yeah
true
there's also a thing of like yeah your
parents played a little fast and loose
it was the 90s
it's jersey you know that [ __ ] happens
90s are great
not yet but it's like it's biting us in
the ass like
yeah a little bit it is a good time
comics for sure it's biting us in the
end yeah but god it was cool
oh it was [ __ ] awesome it was a good
thing so funny there's like this like
the big pc movement or whatever and i'm
like you should literally hear
any family party that i have it's
[ __ ] insane
it's insane it's crazy yeah holy [ __ ] i
love it
um all right so let's go back okay
you can pick whichever house because you
said there was two of them let's do the
new one the in-ground pool house
the in-ground pool the bi-level
in-ground pool yes yes most of my life
so we're going to ask you a series of
questions to determine
you know whether you're garbage we're
going to go back to the beginning here
we're going to we're going to we're
going to start fresh
um what was the name what was the name
of the street that that house was
on colfax drive coal fax drop that's not
too bad i like it
my drives are okay you know it's not
like a pike or true
right you know you're up on a pike yikes
cul-de-sac involved in this place yeah
well yeah it was
were you in the cul-de-sac are you on
the road i'll tell you on the call in
the closet
all right all right clean living baby
got a gentleman in the [ __ ]
all right okay see what was the the
basketball net situation was there one
in the cul-de-sac for every
every house or did you have one in your
driveway or none at all uh kid across
the street
had one i had one when space jam came
out
you know you fill it with sand or
whatever that's the trashiest stuff and
then it broke yeah
that's awesome yeah i got a we have a
pole just in our drive a black pole
that has about i'd say conservatively 45
pounds of concrete
holding it into the ground yeah i think
ain't going nowhere no my dad went real
hard that summer we dug
it was like [ __ ] cool and luke we dug
a hole
and then filled her up with [ __ ]
quikrete that thing ain't going anywhere
nice dude growing up in this cul-de-sac
did you ever have was there any beefs
with any other neighbors for like you
know
years or times where you're like oh
that's the [ __ ] robinsons [ __ ] them
they
you know blew their leaves on my yard or
anything
my father had issues with people okay i
like your dad by the way
but it was like they weren't necessarily
aware of it there's a lot of
internalization yeah you know it's a lot
of
we know about it and we heard about it
and it was a lot more our problem than
it was their problem sure
yeah yeah there was a handful of you
know people who who might be a pedophile
yeah yeah he had like a lot of open
cases yeah a lot a lot of that
damn everybody knew he was a cop right
yeah yeah so
nobody probably [ __ ] with them people
like having cops like that in there cops
on the block yeah
yeah i love it for sure i remember my
dad told a 16 year old kid he was going
to clean his clock
i was like he was walking across the
front yard i'm like this
ain't good my mom's like go inside i'm
like get the [ __ ] out of here i'm
watching this go down
a front row seat yeah i know when my
when my oldest sister was in high school
my dad was much like younger so he was
really more good yeah
and so she had a lot of issues like that
where she'd be at a party all of a
sudden my dad would show up
lighting
he showed up with my uncle once to a
party she was at
and they swung open the door and my dad
was like are you
you know joe whatever and the kid was
like yeah and then my uncle punched him
why why because my uncle knew my dad was
gonna punch him
and his dad would have gotten in trouble
so he was like let me punch this [ __ ]
kid
that's a [ __ ] what did the kid do
though other than having just had a
party and
they were like they were putting masks
on and scaring people on the street
and so the cops got called and then you
know they showed up there was liquor at
the party and then my sister got brought
to the police station and the
dad got her at the station and then was
like where the [ __ ] does the kid live
my sister was like i don't want to tell
you and then he's like this is like a
movie yeah that's
[ __ ] awesome i didn't get any of that
though i didn't get any of that he was
older at that point
yeah yeah older and just he wasn't
coming to get you sitting there just
sitting there did you ever get arrested
at a party like that
no no no no your sister was a bit of a
hellraiser huh yeah yeah yeah dude the
fact that your uncle
punched that dude is [ __ ] good that's
movies he's still around he's a good man
that's like badass movie scene like you
just don't see it coming [ __ ] right
hook [ __ ] i
love it yeah he's awesome [ __ ]
punching kids yeah dude
yeah man these [ __ ] teenagers might
be the party
that pulse nightclub shooting happened
he called me and he was like hey scott
uh i go hey he goes oh thank god i i
didn't know if you were at that
nightclub
i was like i'm in jersey just thinks
it's hilarious
that he could like say i'm gay
i'm just a really ballsy guy he's a good
time
i want to make sure you weren't at that
i was just shooting at an antique store
i want to make sure you're all right
um holy [ __ ] all right very cool very
okay
okay interesting
did you have an israeli did you have a
weird mailbox growing up or was it a
regular did you ever see like those you
know did you have like a mailbox that
was like a dog or a bunny or anything oh
we had
like on and off mailbox like it always
changed positions
where wherever it landed kinda like oh
it's here now
yeah and so you just kind of push it in
the corner that is nothing
that's the thing it's like we gotta buy
level things are very nice but you
it's not being maintained for sure of
course oh let's do an addition but then
we never finish it so this is
is there a hole in the wall what do you
mean it's just like the inside of it is
unfinished it's just not a thing you
could
you know it's non-existent it was like
my dad's friend was doing it and then
my dad's friends started doing heroin
it's like lethal weapons
like my dad's friend went on like a
heroin binge my dad was like you don't
ever come back here again
or something you know so like is it
enclosed
is there a roof on it or is it oh
there's a roof on it yeah there's a roof
are there walls
walls of the in the last like two years
we've got walls but there's not still
like plastic tarp hanging down and like
tools and [ __ ]
i think there is i think there's some
tools
there's definitely some tools yeah dude
that's
[ __ ] that's trash baby yeah but then
you finish it and then my aunt wants to
move in
that was like once my dad died it was
like you know my aunt like hey
what are we gonna do what are you gonna
do with up there and then this place and
it's just you you know you don't want a
dog who's the aunt is it the
is it your mom's sister my mom's sister
yeah so she wants to move in there are
they tight
yeah they're really right they're real
tight yeah holy [ __ ] did he used to
drive the squad car home and park it in
the house no
no no because i guess it's only when you
have yeah and when like
specifically you are an officer who has
a car you know not every car like so
when you're the captain you don't have a
yeah what are they calling the auto pool
or the
car somebody probably drove him around
yeah i don't know how it works i'm
probably yeah captain probably a driver
yeah right i don't know i
i really don't know i never race this
guy
dude a wobbly mailbox and an unfinished
edition yeah we are off
[ __ ] captain chaplin's place who used
to cut the grass
landscaper you did it um us for a minute
like my
my mom for a minute like when i was a
kid i remember my mom doing all the tips
your mom would do anytime you see a the
woman cut in the ground my step on a
riding mower too
yeah riding her push she's pushing like
she's not like a tough
you know she doesn't look like a brawly
[ __ ] lady
but always did the things yeah around
the house she always had like a hand
like she if i went to her house tomorrow
she'd have a hammer in her hand no doubt
just
doing stuff yeah just doing some [ __ ]
yeah get her in the audition
hang some drywall you know yeah what the
hell is she retired now
yeah yeah yeah she hasn't worked since
i've been born oh wow really
okay good [ __ ] captains got good
bennies yeah yeah
good bennies yeah she's doing all right
and they stayed together the entire time
except yeah yeah but they were
yeah you know i mean in the end there
was uh love
and sure all that stuff but yeah it was
most bumpy he was sleeping on the couch
yeah okay all right very good
interesting what was the name of the
grocery store that your mom would go to
growing up
uh food town and uh shoprite shop rights
shop right shopper it's great they
they got good ones rich
i was actually surprised when you said
wildwood crest how close are you to the
south jersey shore probably two and a
half hours two or three hours yeah
is in there is it like long branching
every other one why
would the second to last one yeah it's
the second to last one but there's
nothing really going on it's all like
my family hated the beach we hated the
beach growing up it was just like
they always pitch it to us as a boring
thing yeah and it was like
we want to go on a ride the boardwalk so
why boardwalk is the boardwalk
and get a cheese steak and then get an
ice cream cone and write a thing it was
never like
be garbage like we never rented a shore
house and went to the beach in the
morning there was never a thing we did
yeah we went down and did the rides yeah
yeah
it was like a corner no mad motel which
is like it's now uh
yeah i know the nomad what do you call
those things uh what
like fancy apartments condos condos i
remember the nomad motel
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah good place man
you get waffles downstairs
i'm telling you wildwood is a [ __ ]
kid in the 90s the trash is coming out
of you like you're taking
uh this house growing up uh
did it have a garage did you have a
refrigerator in the garage
no we had we my dad got like a mini
fridge in
the living room okay mini fridge in the
bar room yeah
filled with what beers and stuff like
that party stuff yeah yeah okay what
about sodas for the kids no
no that was upstairs okay yeah we always
had soda yeah big soda fam
not anymore but because as a kid soda
yeah that's all
i remember uh we would carpool and i
remember walking out one morning
to my ride as like a i was probably six
with like a little cup with like doritos
stacked in it
and then some soda and i remember them
like judging me hard
oh yeah soda big time dude nothing was
better than soda and doritos
oh my god like a gatorade bottle for
basketball practice once she gave me
pepsi i swear to [ __ ]
yeah and then i remember i complained
about it so she gave me
uh iced tea the next time powdered what
i swear
yeah yeah how did i see which is
delicious yeah yeah yeah but yeah i'd go
to basketball practice and like
jeans just jeans
you're trash [ __ ] the chaplin kid
showing up [ __ ] drinking gatorades
but then i put all the things you pull a
fonzie you know
yeah like fonzie didn't do [ __ ] and it
worked it works out you're cool
yeah you don't know it's because you
can't do anything you know
you're standing in the corner
doritos eating doritos out of a solo cup
i'm good coach
how about you take a lap yeah exactly
why did you put timmy in again i was
just incapable so i
acted like it was gay if you weren't
capable
oh my god oh that's too good what about
uh
dinners would you guys would you guys
sit at the dining room table and have
dinner would you sit in front of the tv
where would that go down
it's like a big back and forth uh
mostly my childhood was in front of the
tv
and then i remember in high school
sitting at the table a lot okay
like london broil and uh buttered
noodles dude oh
yeah butter noodles buttered noodles
good night let me tell you something
about london broil
london broil because i thought it was
the thing
and then you have you hear london you're
like that's gotta be you have every
other type of steak after
the [ __ ] is going on dude i feel bad
like i don't ever want to cook for my
mom
because it's so much better that like i
don't want to be like yeah dude i don't
know
you couldn't yeah sauce right there
yeah it's called salt ma you ever hear
of it oh
no a lot of salt a lot of salt on
everything but that was it it was just
salt on things salt and butter when i
was a kid
uh we thought london broil and twice
baked potatoes you know what they are
those frozen jars that would they're
like oh you do the frozen
we used to get them we make them oh no
we've got them frozen
frozen that makes something it's a it's
a half of a baked potato
but then they take the the potato out of
it and they mix it with like cream
cheese or whatever they make it's like
mashed potatoes
it's like mashed potatoes and a potato
it's [ __ ] fantastic dude well we
thought that and [ __ ]
paprika on the top of it yeah a little
paprika on top making everything look
real
[ __ ] classy very nice but london
broil man
we thought we were big big in the house
living like kings
yeah london i remember like later on the
later years i was living with my mom
she she figured out uh chicken parm oh
that was big
when they when they get something and
the catch is on oh
man she still makes chicken every party
this chicken parmesan
invite
did you buy or have you ever worn your
class ring
no okay
i remember they gave me the brochure to
buy them for like 15.
[ __ ] for like 1300 bucks i'm like dude
all the time when i start wearing
jewelry like i'm in the mob
straight season 870 on my sats
no way patty polly's laying down for
that i'm trying to forget this [ __ ] ever
happened bro
i'm lucky i got the cap and gown holy
[ __ ]
i did get a letterman jacket though she
she sprung for that for the football
jacket oh that's nice yeah that was
you need that though if you're on the
you were on the team yeah i was on the
team
got a jersey going up she just we're
like friends with yeah he's a big fan
it was weird because he got him when he
was 22. so
i just loved the game but yeah i
remember dude trying to pull off those
[ __ ] class
you got to go to the enable like the
naval academy to work even in college
some guy like our parents generation
like i remember my uncle would wear like
like an awesome villanova
like class ring you know but he was a
[ __ ] he was he went to
he played football there in the 70s it's
a little thing you saw dudes your own
age
in the 90s or early 2000s walking around
with a [ __ ] cabrini college glass
ring
it's like yo take a [ __ ] hike i found
my dad's as a kid
in like a box at my mom's like [ __ ]
roman catholic 1970
what six or whatever and i took it i'm
like because i'm like i was like
it's a different time and i was like
part of it i know and 17 was like 42.
yeah yeah and so i was like yes a ring
for my adult body
but i was like it doesn't make any sense
i found it and i went to him like like
he had i mean he was already out of the
house for a decade at that point point
or whatever i'm like oh yo here i found
this she's like you should what are you
gonna wear it you know i was like a kid
or whatever he's like
no we don't do that i'm like all right
man all right i guess we don't wear it
we are a non-jewelry household for men
straight up your ears pierced yeah oh
that's [ __ ] good stuff
man um yeah okay so
your basic defense here is that sure you
know
it was a little murky when i was a kid
but now you're saying you're all class
is that correct
yeah i didn't know this was part of it
he had blue hair
[Music]
and we also know you're big into what we
what we is
now referred to as the world wrestling
as world wrestling entertainment
yeah well no no i don't like world
wrestling entertainment you're still wwf
or no no no you're that's too commercial
no yeah like
i like new japan pro wrestling uh that's
like japan
progress njpw that's like that's like
wrestling hipster [ __ ]
yeah yeah something yeah it's my
favorite so you never even heard it was
that you gotta like wake up at
six in the morning to watch it was that
so you don't so you don't go for the uh
the commercialization of
uh it's not commercialization wwe you
know i like
watching dudes wrestle you know and you
don't really get that with uh
was new japan ever big japan no like all
japan no they're two separate companies
okay are you like a ring of honor guy i
liked ring of honor for a while i
haven't watched it in a minute but yeah
yeah yeah i used to go to ring of honor
shows yeah
are you familiar with cold cabana yeah i
know kolkata i know of col cabana yeah
[Laughter]
ah yeah so that's uh that's that's gonna
work against you a little bit
yeah um i got one have you ever
have you ever worn a hole but i like it
because it's like ballet i used to go to
my girlfriend's dance recitals and i
thought it was like beautiful art
sure of course and that's why i like
wrestling because i like that
crash think like oh no he's watching it
like it's
shakespeare yeah and you're watching a
niche version of it oh yeah
it sucks boys look i'm i'm uh
[Laughter]
you can't be like i i'm a twinkie guy
but i'm like really a twinkie
oh it's the way i do it is different but
only the seasonal ones yeah no
the people glistening they know okay all
right
all right uh have you ever uh have you
ever worn a hard rock cafe t-shirt
i think i bought like a band t-shirt
from hard rock cafe yeah
i thought there was like a cool stone
shirt or something
that's on the fence if it was a pure
hard rock it's trash
yeah but i was a young man you know you
live in jersey you come over to times
square you're 15.
that's fancy at that point i'm like who
is that that's not fancy forever i
walked to school with a hard rock cafe
shirt that i bought
that i took the bus into manhattan the
sleeves rolled up you're doing it oh i
went there by
myself yesterday i tell everybody
that's classy oh new york city i was
there oh yeah i hopped the bus dude i
listened to the eight-mile soundtrack
the whole time
i had to shake a guy down yeah picked up
a shirt and came back
um two-part question if i may yes uh
have you ever snapped your fingers
instead of clapping
yes yeah i've done that yes that's trash
can you whistle with your fingers
is it like oh no but i can whistle hit
it
hold up away from the mic a little bit
oh god
um i feel judged [ __ ] off dude you're
making me feel like a loser we're a
loser
okay because you think i'm going for
like a like a street garbage whistle no
no no no ready
there's an eloquence to it almost like a
bird i got there at first it kind of
sounded like [ __ ]
but you go who is this gene kelly
[Laughter]
i'm saying yeah you go is this [ __ ]
fred astaire i don't know
i'm not whistling at a [ __ ] umpire i
don't hate it i'm whistling you know
as i tap dance down the steps as i leave
here
i'm a gentleman out the door on your way
to the motel yeah
all right okay play an instrument no i
have a guitar
you just did what are you talking about
i have a guitar
you have a guitar electric or acoustic
it's acoustic
you never studied whistling like
professionally did you i don't think
anybody knows
that that's trash
eloquent people know that it's from the
heart yeah your study was hinted at
yeah that's what he has is born dude
garbage people think that like anything
could be a thing
yeah did you study that no actually you
don't have to study everything that's
how stupid it is
that's how dumb he is and i'm a genius
and i'm a whistling genius
i've never seen somebody so mad about
their beautiful beautiful whistle
i'm a [ __ ] great whistler because i'm
pretty good at it it's like just such
this like light fl it was beautiful
so adamantly defending it it's great oh
my god
the whole thing this guy anyone in your
family ever collect marble miles
um what does that mean i don't know if
they don't okay then no it's like the
points when you smoke marbles you can no
no no
no my father smoked and till
like a high you know but he quit he
drank a lot when he quit yeah but no
there was no
game he didn't play games we didn't play
games no board game there's no board
games at the house
we didn't play games no lottery you play
the lottery
no i wonder why you can whisper uncles
would give them as gifts but they were
like outsiders
yeah but in the house no no that's
another trash thing lottery scratch off
lottery tickets for gifts
yes they're big no board games what else
weren't you allowed to do could you
we weren't allowed to it wasn't like
board you know board games were [ __ ]
weird they just weren't promoted
yeah it's just we weren't doing that
okay uh
yeah i don't know i had a lot of
slingshots and stuff rockets
fun things yeah would you kill things
with them but now you go like no i never
kill a thing
um but we'll get to that i don't know if
you're gonna ever ask a question about a
thing
specifically but anyway um but even like
you know i had like
i had like slingshots and stuff but it
was because i wanted to be
like like huck finn and stuff yeah like
dennis the menace yeah like i wanted to
be like the things i read
sure i'm just defending myself when it
comes to no it's not no i get it all
right so what's the thing you didn't
know i was going to ask that
we'll get to oh i worked at a
slaughterhouse for like five oh that's
right
[Music]
[Music]
i never killed anything i was like a
janitor i only broke knee caps
i'd give them the warning i would clean
up the [ __ ] i would feed them
and then i indeed it's not a promotion
but at some point i started i would
carry
like their dead bodies from the kill
floor
into another room and hang them on a
hook dude at this point but at this
point they didn't look like animals so
let's start
let's start because they were skinned
let's go back
how old were you when you started this
job and where was it at 20
22. 222 you're living at home at your
parents
uh okay so 23 i moved back home after my
father passed away
okay and then yeah and it's in my it was
in my hometown okay
my my oldest sister married the the guy
who owns it it's a little bit of cake
was the fact did you know about the
place when you were growing up like oh
that's a slaughterhouse yeah i tried to
let some animals out when i was a kid
and [ __ ] like
really around there well then they got
you working for yeah yeah [ __ ]
so your sister married one of the rich
guys in town who owned this lost
it's not no it's like a slaughterhouse
but it's not
it's a little bigger than the slaughter
apartment i think they're going wait
really it's a
it's a boutique operation i mean the the
property is
not even that large but it's enough but
the actual like the kill floor and where
we cut things yeah it's like this big
and
hold on look because i'm getting a
picture here who would they sell it to
was it like artisanal means usually
muslims it was like halal
oh that was probably not do any pig
right uh
yeah some days some days it would be
like specifically halal
yeah and then other days it was like
okay so it was a small operation
super small man yeah i don't know i
don't want to eat it i don't eat the
[ __ ] that they killed
you're eating london bro you're not
going to try something oh no cause okay
so
we're killing no chicken balls once a
month
once a month uh once a month
they'd have like a cow that they'd kill
okay and then that would smell good like
when they were cutting it i go ooh that
smells like something i'd want to eat
wow but the goat and the sheep it's
gross so they're coming alive and stuff
like that
yeah yeah the animal's coming alive yeah
yeah it's terrible yeah you've seen some
[ __ ] haven't you yeah
yeah water slides in slaughterhouses
it's the most new jersey [ __ ]
you know holy story ever
huh the slaughterhouse but now i don't
work there no more see
[Laughter]
up and up when was the last time you
smoked a black and mild never i don't
smoke cigarettes wow i don't think i've
ever tried a cigarette wow good for you
okay i have a question for you now okay
like as
like now not when you were a kid but now
you're dying of thirst
okay you can have anything that you want
but it can't be water
what is it gonna be uh
strawberry arizona oh my
gosh raspberry raspberry what it doesn't
matter it's trash if
you buy arizona it ain't good raspberry
i don't know arizona
yeah something like that the raspberry
lemonade tea
no i don't like the lemonade teas
lemonade is too sweet for me
what's silly what am i a whistler silly
people you drink something that's sweet
and you go what are you
[ __ ] silly it's a lot it's a lot it's
a lie i love it
it's yeah it's whimsical raspberry tea
lemonade
good night yeah yeah lemonade so yours
would be a raspberry arizona
raspberry arizona man now you came in
here and said you didn't think you were
garbage
where do you think that falls well
because i'm insane you know i'm not i'm
not like you know
you're not classy i like i get nothing
no but i'll be sweet to you you're nice
yeah yeah
you're nice too but we're trash yeah
yeah yeah like you're a great guy
yeah you're just trash i thought it
would be fun to wiggle
let me give myself a challenge i said
i'm not a piece of [ __ ]
and we're gonna and i'll figure it out
and it didn't work
um all right i got some more for you
growing up were you like a were you a
styrofoam household like styrofoam
plates
styrofoam dude dude that made me feel
like a kid when you said styrofoam
would you bite the cup cause i still see
styrofoam but i don't say styrofoam i
don't hear the word styrofoam dude i've
eaten sleeves
of styrofoam cups dude styrofoam dude
the styrofoam cups suck they were like
this big you got like two ounces yeah
but let me tell you something you packed
that with ice and put some [ __ ] saudi
in there
i would so the way styrofoam cups would
work is like there's a little design
on it yeah would you like bite out the
design i would like the ridges
yeah i would do that sometimes i would
bite i would take like a
half an inch off and then another half
just to the point and i would spit like
that yeah pizza's back in it it would
just sit there
i used to like make like a little
because we're trash got that that's why
damn
i would bite a whole i would bite like a
like a teeth mark in the top and i'd let
it like flap open and that's where the
where the soda would come out that's
kind of cool
did you suck your ice and spit it back
into your drink well yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you're trash i love
it
you are dressed have you ever ordered
anything other than pizza from domino's
or pizza hut
uh yeah or something
yeah i always try the wings and i always
think
they're bad but you try them like
once every you know nine months or
something uh
that and then i like getting the
desserts like the brownies and the
cinnamon sticks and uh
dominoes cinnamon sticks i used to like
the cheesy bread but
that's kind of appetizer
that's for like a you know you're trying
to impress somebody when you're already
you get the cinnamon sticks for you
that's like maybe a bunch of kids here
or something you know you want to be
cool
yeah yeah i do the domino's lobster wait
nine bucks domino's lava cakes man oh
yeah those are great
i've eaten four of them at a time dude i
love a hot cookie with some
ice cream oh yeah from domino's no just
in general oh just in general that's
great
heating up a cookie you're throwing ice
cream i'll tell you i remember
the first time i ever had a heated
[ __ ] brownie with ice cream on it was
that applebee's oh yeah
i thought we were the richest family in
a [ __ ] philadelphia yeah
lava cake and it kind you go it kind of
looks like it you say that your family
goes kind of looks like lava
kind of looks like classic yeah i
remember trash
the specific day that i figured out that
hershey's chocolate syrup was not the
same as hot fudge
and then at the end of the [ __ ] ice
cream i've never been the same
and i've never looked back i'll have my
vengeance in this life or another but
then i remember at the end of the ice
cream aisle one day i looked up and i
saw the smucker's hot fudge that comes
it looks like in a jelly container yeah
yeah yeah yeah
you take home and the same lid yeah yeah
that and the magic show remember when
your
my mom would be like is that the thing
the europeans eat she would have no idea
yeah yeah
if you're making uh chocolate milk what
are you what syrup are you using
her hair yeah yeah all day i didn't even
know there were other options
some people like bosco they're like
bosco nestle's quick
i got a thing of bosco at like uh like a
minor league baseball game like yeah the
bosco truck was there and gave everybody
samples
it was ass no good come in this town
again punk
i would that's quick was new money [ __ ]
if you had nesquik it was like the
lottery
and then you have nesquik for the first
time wow yeah
powder very like i don't know
it was too i love it i needed hershey's
had a bit of grit to it
you know my grandma always kept some
strawberry hershey's and it was like a
nice treat
yeah yeah nice dream [ __ ] you were
classy if you hadn't
i stayed away from the kids that drink
strawberry milk that was my sister love
strawberry milk i didn't i didn't
i remember one time they must have been
selling it in bulk or got a deal my mom
bought america's choice which was super
fresh at the time so it was america's
choice
uh chocolate syrup instead of hershey's
they must have been like 10 for 10 or
something and she just i don't know
we ended up for like three years
straight that's all we had
it was the dark ages of my [ __ ]
household i hated it
cheese whiz was big cheese how about the
spray cheese
spray cheese yeah yeah smiley faces all
day dude i had spray cheese within
90 days it's [ __ ] still as good as it
was
sure it don't it don't taste like any
other cheese yeah and any other cheese
now it has bacon flavor now too
really that's interesting were you a
bacon bits family
no no no bacon bits no if you guys went
out to dinner
like if your dad took you that what are
the bacon bits exactly like fake bacon
oh drink them on the side we weren't
like we were in a breakfast family
or whatever those things it would be
like breakfast you're having breakfast
but you know once every two years when
we took a big test
no these just sprinkle on salad bacon
bits oh oh no i mean i've had that yeah
yeah where would your dad take you to
dinner
uh this place called charlie brown's
okay yeah
i know charlie brown's there's a few of
them and then there's a pumpkin queen
uh diner uh by me that's where you go
diner yeah
i like it all right i think uh i got a
couple here from the patreon members
uh guys when you sign up for patreon we
will ask your questions
uh because we just get so many um
submissions from everybody on [ __ ]
youtube
facebook everywhere but if and we'll try
to get to them all but when you do join
patreon we will answer
we will ask your question um that being
said
this is from sean have you ever owned a
dr seuss hat
because i for sure have that's a home
run of a question oh man
that's a [ __ ] great question but it
wasn't it wasn't for dr
seuss you know what i mean like it was a
dr seuss like the style the version
the hat hat but i think it was like new
york rangers yeah either way they're
trash
yeah the royal family isn't wearing
those around the house
have you ever signed up for a credit
card at a sporting event to get like the
free towel or whatever no but brother i
i am in debt
to hot topic right now it's a hot topic
[ __ ]
they call me every six times a day when
did you get it
uh like four years listen you're dealing
with how would you get a hot topic
because i couldn't get a credit card
anywhere and i was trying to buy
christmas gifts
and i couldn't find a credit card
anywhere and then i was in hot topic
just getting a thing for myself you know
whatever and then like an adult
yeah and then and then i heard the lady
offer someone a
20 off yeah so then she asked me and i
said sure and i assumed i wasn't going
to qualify and i
qualified and i cleaned house dude oh
that percentage
i got two chain wallets no i spent the
match was like 400 i could spend 400
dollars
for christmas gifts um and then uh
ignored the bill and now it's like a
thousand something listen this is what
they do
i can get you out of this group do you
talk to them or no no
buddy this is what you do yeah you
answer the call grab me a lava lamp yeah
no answer the call
and what they'll do is they have a
settlement number that they'll give you
right because they bought that i went
through this with macy's they bought
that money for pennies on the
dollar okay because hot topic goes this
isn't hot topic that's called hot
topic's not calling you third party no
it's third parties
so hockey that sounds scary like a
lawyer yeah
it's all because it's not some girl from
hot tub hey this is tiffany scott can
you come pay your bills
don't even try me scott they'll offer
you because they bought your 400
of debt for like 200 bucks right and
then
the first company couldn't collect it so
they sold that 200 bucks for like 100
bucks
and then they couldn't collect it and
they said so you might be i remember the
one time dude because the messages
they've been leaving me now it's like
hey we know covid might have you messed
up
they're look because they're like i'm
gonna pick up yeah they say anything
they'll say anything i had i had a dude
who got me he really got me he scared
the [ __ ] out of me when i was in my 20s
she was calling my brother's place where
i lived
yeah when i was a kid i had a cell phone
when i was in middle school i think
and i'd get phone calls and one guy was
like your mommy's going to go to jail
and now you look at it now you're like
there's no way yeah yeah no there's no
such thing as debtor's prison in the
united states um
i've researched these laws yeah your
mommy's going to jail
you haven't met my dad [ __ ] i'll tell
you that she ain't going anywhere
captain of aquatic dog hit the bricks
wait kimmy you you didn't finish
how to resolve this so the so that they
don't have for them they don't have the
listeners yeah for the listeners they
don't have a thousand dollars invested
into that money they might have
[ __ ] 120 or something i don't know
what it is
but the longer it goes the less and less
they have invested in the money
um because i remember one time that i
owed macy's [ __ ]
900 bucks or something for ever for like
[ __ ] 60 or seven years so finally
answer the phone i'm like i go what do
you i have like 500 bucks on my account
i'm like i'm just getting out in front
of this i'm like all right i'm like what
do i have to pay you
for you to stop calling me yeah they
must have called me fifteen thousand
times in the seven years i said what do
i have to pay you today
to stop calling me goes 37 bucks i go
the [ __ ]
later dude here you go 37 scott
your your credits [ __ ] but it's all
right
i need to go to hot topic yeah i'll
still go to hot topic too and like drop
like a 25 you know what are you buying
at hot tubs
he's wearing a disguise they sell
wrestling t-shirts they sell wrestling
t-shirts
i swear to god i do get freaked out
sometimes you look a lot like scott
chaplin
oh no not me i'm from canada big porn
star
up in canada
oh my god i got one more from uh
christopher
uh is it garbage to become a member of a
men's only restricted social club for
cheap beer and gambling
asking for a friend like the elks lodge
knights of columbus
the what else the moose lodge they're
great i think it depends where you come
from that could be
that could be a good move for somebody a
small town in a certain town
especially especially if the the the
clubhouse or whatever
like you know like the the vfw wherever
the actual yeah
that's like a lifeline has been redone
yeah the bar is nice you can go there
watch your game not get your balls broke
have a roast beef sandwich that's clean
or you know what dude become a
this guy he wants to make friends
obviously volunteer fire
he's going like him yeah am i going to
be a loser if i join this club
if you want friends be a volunteer
firefighter these guys really think
they're like doing things
like yeah it brings them together man
they think they're like heroes you know
right
but you just get to hang out and watch
nascar or whatever yeah
my family's were uh elks lodge in
wildwood
it's like you go in there it's like
[ __ ] nickel beers and it's like going
back to 1922. it's [ __ ] fantastic
that's nice yeah that's nice if you're
ever low on cash looking to drink on the
cheap
go to an american legion oh american
legion's big too yeah
yeah yeah but you got to be a guest to
somebody to get in it's like hey who are
you with
those dudes yeah i haven't been in
america parties used to be held at like
yeah oh yeah did you ever have you ever
gone to a wedding
their food's always top shelf yeah
mashed potatoes
and meatballs i don't know chicken fried
cheese dudes yeah
yeah they always have chicken chicken
dinner rolls are always on point the
only dressing was ranch they [ __ ] did
it right
yeah all right i want to
uh do you brush your teeth in the shower
let's get this
that's not trash that's how you properly
do it no
i do it too cause you because you got to
get crazy with a toothbrush like if you
really want to get the nasty out of your
mouth you gotta
you gotta let like some suds come out of
your face and whatnot you're not going
to stand in front of the mirror like
that
yeah i know it's trash i brush my teeth
in the shower teeth in the shower
but it's been determined here on the
podcast that that's garbage
everybody said it's not santa you leave
the toothbrush in there no
okay so you won't leave the toothbrush
in there but you'll do the act in there
so you know that it's dirty in there
yeah
the thing is it also knows he's in the
sink though you do yeah this is no sorry
not a rib
i'll pee i pee in the sink like more
than
into a toilet dude you are garbage
wait why uh i think i know why
i don't does your girl does your
girlfriend break your balls about pee
getting on the floor no i don't pee on
the floor dude i got pretty good aim i
don't you got a good piece on you
you don't like touching uh toilet like
flusher
you know i'm talking when i'm out and
about okay at like a restaurant or a bar
wait they'll pee in the bar if i stop in
some you know like at a thing
no wait like a gallery opening what do
you mean okay yeah if there's a gallery
opening and i
and and it's you're not going away what
are you talking about dude if you
remember how i
[ __ ] before right yeah but i told you i
had to piss if i had to pace there's a
chance i would have pissed in that sink
out there
wow nuts wait because you immediately
[ __ ] ready
you immediately hit the faucet it goes
down right
sure goes down and then uh and then soap
right away you don't have to there's not
a lot of touching things
you don't have to walk over to a thing
that makes your shoes sticky
but at a point i'm avoiding garbage bags
at a public place what if somebody
walked in you were
no no i won't do i won't do it you know
you got a star boxer yeah you have to
assess this
starbucks oh if i could lock the door
yes yeah yeah i do
i do no i haven't done it no while while
you can't lock the doors
yeah so i haven't done it at wawa
because do it at home or no
no no no no so it's a sanitary thing for
your hands it's a sanitary thing out in
a bag
[ __ ] everybody else though i'll tell you
that i'm splashing cold water on my face
and i clean you know and then i i i
round the bowl with the water i splash
it around the bowl a little
oh well that's real nice of you yeah
it's pretty bizarre soap
i could see doing it i do it at the
house every once in a while and you get
to look at yourself in the mirror you
get to look at yourself in the mirror
you know
did you does your girl know you do it do
you do it in the [ __ ] no
nobody does so everybody keep it quiet
oh you'll do it sometimes at home if my
girlfriend's in the bathroom
and i have to listen my girlfriend's in
the bathroom and i have to pee really
bad
i'll go and get on my tippy toes in the
kitchen sink and i'll pee in the kitchen
soon oh but you
rush you rush that [ __ ] yeah yeah but
then you're doing the dishes
i wipe it all out it don't blow do you
spit in the kitchen sink it's all pipes
uh yeah i'm bad which i'm i i blow my
nose into the sinks
and then and then rinse them down and
they're wrong and i blow my nose you
snot rocket i don't even know how to
snot rocking
that's not rocking in the shower no my
body goes here yeah i don't have the i
don't have the lung capacity
where are we going yeah yeah to the chin
wow dude you're an animal
thank you not having dinner at your
place anytime soon
[ __ ] nasty are you double join it
no i'm a lefty though can you do
anything with your feet
anything weird play piano or
pick things up play the good no i mean i
could probably eat a thing
i could probably hold a fork in my with
my feet i think i could probably do it
have you ever tried
i think i might have tried you know when
you're younger hacky sack
i've tried it not good not good at it
that was a big hacker what about
juggling can you juggle you look at your
juggling tried hard cunning
devil sticks did you try to play the
devils dude uh
no i mean i you know i couldn't do it
but yeah i never bought those
but i couldn't do any of that stuff
scott wanted to be that guy he couldn't
that's even dressier
i couldn't do any like magic kits and
then you can't do it you go what is
happening
i couldn't do it man you couldn't set
off a rocket in the back you had to see
this plenty of i had rockets
holy [ __ ] when you go to uh the pharmacy
cvs ready do you walk through the toy
aisle to see what they have
i don't buy though i don't
he said that like yeah [ __ ] got you i
don't bother you go to see what
wrestlemania
i want to know what the kids are the
kids are into usually when you say that
you mean like high school kids yeah
i want to see what the seven-year-olds
are i don't know what the kids are
consuming
but yeah cause the wrestling figures i
like seeing you know oh that guy looks
like that you know i'm with you i got
one
have you ever bought a chain necklace
with a charm
i don't know like a charm but i remember
you'd get like the fake
as an adult my eyes now would go no
don't do that
but when you're a little kid a lot of
like you know
new york yankee like fake diamond chains
yeah
and i remember having one on a hat like
a big diamond
new york yankees like symbol that was
like clipped onto the hat you know
yikes yeah i had a dragon at one point
i was not dragging kind of cool i did i
did some dragon [ __ ] i would like to
wear dragons
they were big how old are you i'm 30.
okay yeah i'm 34. they were big back in
like
when i was in like junior high dragons
were [ __ ] in dude yeah i knew so i
knew some kids who like
who [ __ ] with dragons hard yeah uh
well like dms like i think
somebody if something was big on jazz
somebody was big on dragging cisco dudes
watch out for this guy unfortunately it
was no cisco cisco had a run from like
99. oh he 2001
yeah dude and it was cool like the video
was cool maybe he just like ran on the
ladies heads yeah it was just
so cool i loved that as a kid dude
yeah come on he's got dumps like a truck
i was a big usher fan usher was like
you're breaking my balls for cisco you
were an usher for this is great
dude yeah but just as no uh sure it's
like fantastic yeah but i think you
could dance to usher i used to dance
hard to usher are you a good dancer
really was a good dancer very good thing
really yeah i'm not lying i like school
dancing
i'm not joking i don't my
my mom said that uh my great-grandfather
could have been like this huge
vaudeville guy but he refused to do
blackface
good friends so they banished him that's
what she told me yeah
she told me i believe in reality
so i can sing i can dance i can whistle
i can do all the things that you know
people could do gotcha yeah
yeah very big usher guy do you know how
to operate a forklift
no okay no do you own a chinese star
right now no no numchucks you stu
used to own nunchucks you have any movie
posters hanging in your apartment
currently
no not currently okay have you ever had
uh orangina no no
anyone in your family ever have a
breathalyzer in their car
no no do you cottage cheese
no have you ever shot a potato gun
yes potato guns have you ever caught a
t-shirt out of a t-shirt gun
no but man i tried don't hold that
against me dude
i [ __ ] trapped trash dead
hard dude
[Laughter]
a dove as hard as i could man taking out
a little kid
have you ever made homemade butt wipes
with a paper towel and some soap and hot
water
no uh no soap just water
yeah unscented huh like wet water okay
i'm not gonna do soap because that's
like a type of soap that you'd have to
like
that then wash out of your ass
why not take a shower i think the
addition of water is more outrageous if
you're hemmed up and you're going
alternative ass wiping [ __ ] methods
no you're trying to wipe your ass yeah
water's the key ingredient yeah just a
touch of soap
not that i've done it yeah especially if
your ass like ain't working with you
yeah
it's the worst have you ever owned a
remote control boat
yes you were never good at working
though no i was i
i had the right time i loved them i had
the guy on the jet ski dude i always
wanted to do a back flip
never has the same thing they [ __ ]
suck those things stink
remote control cars yes loved remote
control
the gas ones are the electric ones
electric okay
all right never got too hardcore no no
fair enough
please have you ever been to a scrap
yard yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah dude
you're trash man yeah scrappy
one time we had four treadmills just all
from the garbage oh my god
yeah have you ever been to medieval
times yeah a lot of bars
a lot of birthdays cause it's right in
easter
yeah it's right in jerusalem yeah yeah
that's why they moved so they could be
closer to [ __ ] medieval times yeah
holy [ __ ] um i think i
have everything i need to know at this
point i render a decision
i would like to know this um if you were
being executed tomorrow what would your
what would your
your last meal be
filet mignon that's good anything from
anywhere
i didn't say anything i just wasn't sure
if you're like the filet mignon
just like i just know if you got to like
pick yeah anywhere
oh yeah like just fresh off the cow okay
you know from your slaughterhouse
that one time a month just something
really you know
uh but yeah like like you know build the
meal take your time build them
rare um some whipped potatoes
and then the uh what's the thing they're
the green asparagus asparagus
who gets asparagus on their last meal
because it's so good because well
because that's
a good comment that's what they put
there yeah i don't think you can get it
in here
i would have got doritos on the side and
then i like doritos
but i don't like the breath that it
gives you like buddy you're getting
you're getting fried right after this
it's your last meal
i don't want the devil making fun of me
all right what about dessert i'm a big
dessert guy love i love anything
chocolate
okay uh lava cake we never had like
uh and i've told people this thing is
really good i don't think i've had pot
like pie
yeah we never had a pie we were we were
in a non-pie
i've seen pie at other people's houses
and then i think i had pie when i was
like 22
or something but the idea of an apple
pie
or a really good i know that that's like
are you a pilgrim like that's what it
felt like it was very
[ __ ] ancient who made is your
grandmother what would be like what's a
dessert your mom would make if you ever
having a special dinner at all no no she
want to make desserts
yeah like entenmann's uh like a crumb
crumb cake big crumb cake
good night oh it's so good right uh yeah
big entenman's crumb cake fans
and i like the entenmann's chocolate
doughnuts oh the rich chocolate fruit
the hardest the hard and the yellow
inside i used to only eat the bottom and
then just go what
throw it out mom dude i would do two of
those in two big [ __ ]
two big solo cups of [ __ ] whole milk
milk was with the cereal and then
whatever was left over
i would do it with sweets oh really you
wouldn't even wait you wouldn't drink
your cereal milk i don't
i don't think i'm saying made just i
don't think i've ever had a glass of
milk i mean obviously i had milk like as
a baby i guess but
i never had a glass of milk chocolate
milk i love chocolate milk but uh
no never a glass okay we're drinking
soda at the bus stop as an elementary
stream
he was drinking a basketball practice
yeah but i don't like soda anymore i
just like water i only drink water and i
drink a lot of water
yeah i do unfortunately that's not gonna
buddy you could drink a [ __ ] you could
drink that above ground pool it ain't
pulling you out of this
unless it's an olympic sized sized pool
of pellegrino
we're gonna have to deem your garbage
unfortunately
buddy dead to rice
i don't think i've ever had somebody
answer yes to almost to 99
of the questions yeah i got some
fantastic
i [ __ ] love it we love you buddy uh
anything you want the folks out there to
know before we let you get out of here
uh no listen to my podcast
absolutely here we go right now garbage
days it kind of sounds like there's
honestly
sometimes i'll see a thing for thurs and
i think it's mine i don't know
i go is that my my podcast which one is
it but i promise it's good i don't like
you know
it's very funny it's very funny yeah
we're not gonna like promote it or
anything with friends
oh no i just mean in life like in life
not here we'll promote it now
but it's very good it's me brennan
sagalow garbage days yeah she was a
previous guest
brendan sagalo previous guest um
absolutely fantastic
kippy what do you got as always uh
thanks for tuning in please make sure
you rate review subscribe on itunes full
video available on youtube
uh patreon.com i'll show you garbage for
bonus content i am at kevin ryan comedy
on all social media
thank you so much for all the support
guys we really [ __ ] appreciate it
absolutely yeah that patreon is cooking
we got a lot of stuff up on there please
go in there and check it out
we love you guys toby we love you buddy
happy holidays to everybody and we will
see you
next week